i gotta say i'm really grateful that you
and i have
maintained a friendship particularly
throughout everything that that's gone
on with jackass yeah and um
and i i really really want you to know
that
even though i don't think you you choose
to believe it the fact is that the whole
you getting your contract canceled or
whatever you want to call it kicked out
of jackass four
was was genuinely the same
as
me getting an intervention from johnny
knoxville you know like the scene
but i got so much to say like in jackass
2 i got
if i've got drunk at the lax airport
with brass knuckles i got a [ __ ]
felony charge and i got high five for
good press now i wind up sipping on a
beer out front of a hotel on tmz and i
get kicked out for for being a liability
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous
okay
i mean i i'll i'll entertain some of
that and and back in the days of jackass
number two we were in our heyday we were
at our worst drugs and alcohol were
still working for us nobody was getting
locked up in rehab or jail or like just
you know having public meltdowns and i i
hope that you can understand that at a
certain point
like specifically over the last few
years
that it stopped being fun
it stopped being funny it stopped being
cool it stopped being something that we
want to give give you a high five for
because we're like we've been watching
you
self-destruct
we can also let the record reflect that
when you had been kicked out of the
movie that i was like oddly surprisingly
like
campaigning to get you back in the movie
and we were so close bam we we had to a
point where yeah
we were so close i know we had
i was like writing scripts for you be
like tell them this say this and it's
gonna help get you back in the movie and
we got you to a point where you had a
zoom call with johnny knoxville spike
jones jeff tremaine and that was
specifically the call where they were
gonna make the decision you were all but
back in and you got loaded and missed
the [ __ ] call you you got loaded and
no showed the call and and they had to
see you once what happened was
yeah i didn't have a computer and i was
rushing to danny wade's house
but they had to see you all wasted on
social media the night before so they
knew exactly why you missed the call and
they were like [ __ ] you know we were
this close to letting them back in but
he made the decision for us
and i was fighting so hard for him
everything meant meant for a reason and
i i'm much better off not being in it
i'm very happy to not be in it i did it
i don't want to do that anymore i don't
want to be a part of it i i'm much
happier without it everything happens
for a reason and and uh you're grateful
for where you're at that's the best
thing i've heard you say this whole
[ __ ] time man and uh i i i was
fighting for you to be in the movie it
didn't work whatever everything worked
out in the end
you're uh happy now that it's on and
over with i i i didn't want to do it in
the first place it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude